Welcome back!
Master!
Princess!
I'm back!
Hello!
Welcome back to Devil May Cry!
I'm gonna do my best to finish the game today!
I'm gonna do my best.
We're on chapter 15?
I think.
I thought this was gonna be DMC3.
No!
DMC1 part 3.
Yeah.
VTuber, you are back!
I'm back, baby!
SirSimplot, thanks for 6 months!
Did you know there's an unused laser cannon found in the game's demo?
Laser cannon!
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh.
I learned something about this game, actually.
I learned something about this game.
Oh my gosh.
I learned that this game was technically supposed to be Resident Evil 3!
Oh my god.
Technically.
Techni...actual...legalities.
Three!
You guys have been saying four!
But that's actually, like, apparently the case.
Like, it was... Oh gosh.
Hold on.
I have to remember what I read.
It was like, Resident Evil... Yeah, Code Veronica was supposed to be Resident Evil 3.
And then this was based off of that or something.
It was like a whole process that happened.
And then just some things happened and it was like passed down generations.
It was some weird thing.
Why are you lying?
I'm not!
I think it was like a bunch of mixed up stuff.
Dozed off over the end of the stream last night, but congrats on unlocking the second most epic bro handshake in video game history.
Thank you!
She's right.
See!
I read that!
The internet wouldn't lie to me.
Actually, the whole project leading up to Resident Evil 4 spawned three different franchises.
That's crazy, right?
I've been watching these streams like a ho...
I won't say that word anymore.
Like a bird, to a certain extent.
You can't get me with Mike.
You can't get me with Bird.
You can't get me!
Bionic Hippo, welcome back!
Hello, hello!
Hikari, welcome back!
Lambris, welcome back!
Hello, hello, hello!
I don't want to waste too much time talking.
Especially because I got to get used to the controls again.
Exotic Milkshake, thank you!
For two months!
Do you prefer Chris Redfield or Leon Kennedy?
I only know more about Leon, in all.
I don't know so much about Chris.
Birdy, welcome back!
Peach, welcome back!
Saku, thanks for the pick!
Just happened to catch you in between meetings, still dealing with big, big work.
It's been a lot, but seeing you be so cute and unabashedly yourself on Twitter...
What am I doing on Twitter?
Thank you, Saku!
Okay.
Chris punched a rock once.
That's some big news.
Everybody should know that.
Spread it.
Spread it online.
Alright.
We cleared mission 14.
Go to the surface and head for the Colosseum.
Oh, we're about to go to the... Oh, we're still doing the Colosseum.
Oh, Wheel of Destiny, use a shield and a pair of lances to conquer the Colosseum.
Oh, no!
Oh, the Colosseum!
Oh, gosh, the Colosseum!
Oh, no!
Oh, gosh.
Hold on.
What do I have?
I have...
My big head is blocking it.
Where should I sit?
I don't wanna, like... Okay, maybe right here in the tippy corner.
Maybe here in the corner.
Let's see.
I have 1200 rorbs.
I've been using... We used it for a little bit.
I use Alistair a lot.
This is the Colosseum mission?
Oh, no!
I gotta get good real fast.
Oh, thank you, Nun!
Good luck on buying Ace Combat Visual Lightstick.
Don't make sure you don't buy horror version.
Okay.
Thrustmaster is better.
I will make sure.
Ifrit is for real gamers?
Stop it.
They're both right.
I have... I accidentally leveled up one of them.
Before.
I don't have enough rorbs for Inferno.
Let's see.
Stinger?
Can't even do a new Stinger.
Level up anyway.
What do I... Maybe I should get, like, a new purple...
A porb.
Maybe I should get a porb.
I don't know.
You know what?
Let's just go in.
I gotta figure out...
I gotta figure out how to play the game again anyway.
Okay.
Oh gosh, I'm nervous.
Who's fighting?
I mean, who's there?
Oh, I have a grenade.
Oh my gosh.
Oh god.
Wait, I'm not ready!
Oh god!
Shoot, how do I fight again?
Oh my god.
Wait.
How do I... Oh, there we go.
How do I fight again?
Oh shoot, guys.
This is not good.
Here's where I learn how to fight!
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
What are you talking about?
That was so cool!
Stingers!
Absolute!
Where are you going, buddy?
Where are you going?
Oh my god.
I got good at the game again.
Are there more?
No.
Oh, I missed.
It would have been way cooler if I hadn't missed.
Dodge!
Oh gosh!
Oh, I'm gonna die here, you guys.
I think... I think I'm gonna die here.
Oh, I can devil trigger.
That's right.
I heal when I devil trigger.
Oh, this guy is dead.
Okay, hold on.
Come here.
Why are you in the corner?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Kill him Dante!
Oh my god.
There is more?
Even still?
Do these guys never stop coming?
I won't let you even...
Oh, we did it.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
Get my rorbs.
Gather my rorbs and my thoughts and my feelings.
Oh!
I love watching my Oshie spam a single move and kill demons.
I did spam it really good though.
Yippee!
And my health is...
Oh, I know Halloween is almost over, but Crow Country is a really good old-school RE-inspired game.
I actually had Crow Country initially on the list of games I wanted to play.
Potentially.
We came from here.
During Halloween.
But I'm not going to lie.
Games like Resident Evil aren't really my favorite types of games.
I don't know.
It's just not so...
More?
Oh my god.
Where?
I think I dilly-dally too much.
Are you dead?
Okay.
So I don't know.
I thought about it.
Maybe in the future.
What was this?
How do I... Oh, there we go.
There's a decoration resembling two knights.
It appears as though the knights should be holding something.
Words are carved beneath the decoration.
The shields that glow with light and a pair of lances shall lead to the battleground.
This is the shield.
Shall I use the emblem shield?
Sure.
I'm scared, you guys.
Gecko, thanks for six months.
Oh, shit.
Die!
God, leave me alone!
What is this?
Who else is here?
No one?
I got a luminite.
A mysterious stone that shines in the dark.
An ordinary stone that exists in the underworld that somehow over time gained different properties in the human world.
Where are you?
Yeah, baby!
Guys, we're all good.
Don't worry about it.
This looks like a crack in the wall.
Oh my gosh!
I might be a genius!
She's gaming.
Yeah.
I'm also getting rich, baby.
A Yorb!
Let's go!
Nothing else.
OK.
Yorb!
Where is this light coming from?
Dante is just God's favorite child, maybe.
We can power up here.
Oh, the luminite.
It's the light of the party.
Air raid?
Become airborne and be capable of performing aerial electrocution attacks.
Yeah, I did get air hike.
So air raid would be good, maybe because of...
how I fight.
I like to jump in the air and...
and do a little something or other, you know?
Get air raid?
OK!
Let's try it out.
You know I still have enough for a Yorb.
Why not?
I'll get both.
But I'll be poor.
Boo.
Oh my gosh!
Ghost!
Welcome to the membership, thank you.
Air raid gives you...
invisibility?
You mean invincibility?
Get the Yorb!
I'm poor.
I'm Yorb!
Oh, wait.
There was a... Oh, this is the door I go through down here.
But I'm... Is there anything here?
OK, I'm good.
No, alright.
Let's go downwards.
I forgot that I came from up the upstairs.
I thought this is where I came from for a second.
Oh, no.
No, not this shit again.
Oh, man.
Come on.
Give me a break.
OK.
3, 2, 1, go.
What the hell is this?
Wait, what is this?
Come on Dante!
Dante!
Get it!
What did I do?
I opened... a thing?
OK, hold on.
And go.
OK.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not going to be able to...
Oh god.
Dante.
Dante, keep going.
Keep going, buddy.
Keep going.
OK, I unlocked something else.
Alright, alright, alright.
What's here?
A little break.
Oh, what's this?
Do I want to go in here?
What is this?
This is the posing room.
Wow, Dante, you look so cool.
Yeah.
Wow, Dante.
Yeah, everybody?
Screenshot time.
The upskirt room.
What is this?
Oh, words are inscribed.
Sacrifices become magical powers and rise to the connecting passage.
To the skywalk.
Sacrifices become magical powers.
OK.
These are a lot of sacrifices already.
Can I break them?
Yeah, so ominous, right?
It's not me, right?
I'm not the sacrifice.
Probably.
I should not fall.
Oh golly.
I see the guys down there.
What is this?
Nothing?
OK.
It's morbid time.
Mii, thank you for the support.
The Colosseum entrusts the conqueror with the lance.
The time has come to open the door.
A pair of lances.
To be held by the knights who guard the gate.
You cannot equip this item.
Yeah, I know.
That's kind of messed up, game.
This is what John and Father Garcia aspired to be in the future?
Probably.
Wait, where am I supp...
I can't see what I'm doing though.
I just jump into the darkness?
How do I use the air raid?
How do I do that?
Ouchie, ouchie.
Sting or jump?
Wait, so...
Wait.
Wait, I gotta get my orbs first.
Devil trigger only mid-air.
OK, OK.
Devil trigger only.
Got it.
I'm wallhacking.
Oh, we're back here.
Oh gosh.
I couldn't see it.
Oh god, OK.
I'm still not sure what this is about, but OK.
I can practice with the refill.
Oh, this is...OK.
What the hell?
Is this it?
Wait, what the hell was that?
That's air raid.
Oh my gosh, OK.
You become a bird?
Now shoot when you fly.
You shoot lightning.
OK, hold on.
Let's try it again.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I'm trying to...
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Ah, I see, I see.
OK, it's the gun button.
OK, it's not sword button.
I understand now.
Lightning is like a gun.
Run, run, run.
Oh my god, oh my god.
This game is so evil.
Who else is around?
Upstairs, I think.
Where is the upstairs?
Where did I come from?
Hello?
Oh, up here.
There it is.
I hear him.
Cause we gotta go do the swords, right?
Give me your money!
Give me your roars!
Recommend you checking out the anime before you start 5.
Well, that's not till a long time from now, so...
Remind me then.
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna double trigger.
I can't see anything.
I think that worked.
Oh, I think that worked.
Are they still around?
Why is there so much laughing?
I think...
I still hear something.
What the hell is that?
Is that inside the Colosseum?
Sleeping dog?
The swords go here.
Right?
Yeah.
The shields that glow with light...
Paralances, yes.
Oh no!
Thank you so much!
Oh gosh.
Thank you!
I can't see it, but thank you so much!
Oh my gosh.
We're inside the Colosseum!
What is happening in here?
Okay.
I'm just observing a little bit.
Right now.
Ducky, thanks for the gift.
Look at what happens with these portals.
That looks like a leggy.
I'm scared, you guys!
I'm scared!
Run for cover!
Thanks for the five gifted!
That looks like another leggy.
Oh no, that's... nevermind.
That's just all broken up.
I don't know if I go into this or the warps.
Hold on, let me see what these do.
Do they hurt me?
Okay, that's what I thought they did.
Okay, save that for...
when we need it.
A Yorb?
I will take it.
A Yorb, Yorb, Yorb!
Any more...
Gorb?
Yes.
Any more...
other treasures?
Any other Yorbs?
Did they give me more than one Yorb?
Okay, the fact that they gave me a Yorb at all makes me...
really nervous.
They are like, we know this is hard.
You need this Yorb.
Where is the Morb?
Bottom right.
Okay, alright.
I hear someone speaking to me inside my mind.
Offer a sacrifice to the Colosseum.
It shall connect the path to the Wheel of Destiny.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh my gosh, wait, it's this guy again.
Oh my god, wait.
It's this hecking guy again.
Oh my god.
Oh, screw this guy.
Why can't I double trigger?
Oh, that saved me actually.
No, no, no!
Oh, I misread it.
Oh my god, I can't see.
I can't fight either.
No, wait.
Wait, why can't I turn into a bird?
Okay, I turned into a bird just to...
Oh gosh, I can't see anything.
Please, please game.
Please game, be kind to me.
Game, I can't see anything!
I think I'm not attacking him.
Where is he?
Let's go!
Wait, but he wasn't... He was like halfway health.
Okay, phase two.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no way.
Spam, Dr. Spam!
Ouchie, ouch.
Am I supposed to... Oh my god.
Am I supposed to avoid that?
Oh, I went right into it.
Go, go!
Double trigger!
Yeah, bitch!
Yes, bitch!
It's okay, I think.
Yeah!
Oh!
Where is he?
I love Air Raid.
Sacrifice.
For the wheel of destiny.
Mundus!
Yeah!
No, no, no.
No, please.
Please no.
Yeah, block off Feather Face!
No.
No!
It really sounded funny that, like, Torzia and Griffin sounded like just a guy with a voice changer.
The three-eyed.
The High Lady, you're here.
Not mom.
Yeah, it was.
Mundus.
Nuh-uh.
Oh my god.
In the name of the Mundus.
Ow!
Kill Mundus!
Mundus!
Why did she leave?
Sailor Dante.
Oh, let's go grab the...
Wait, what's my health looking like?
Yeah, let's go grab the...
These don't work anymore?
Are you kidding me?
Oh, come on!
But I want the Grorb.
I can't get the Grorb anymore!
Their raid is too powerful.
Glad we talked about it in the last stream.
I know what you're saying is sad, but I can't hear you over the piano.
Okay, maybe here I can dump, because I couldn't see before in the other...
No!
Dante.
Alright, stand there.
There we go.
Okay, we made it.
Thank you, thank you.
Easy peasy, that's my gamer Oshi.
Colosseum conquered, baby.
Maybe we can just fall into it from here.
Dramatic!
I overestimated a little bit.
What is this thing anyway?
Hello?
Oh, come on!
Dante, stand on top of it.
Dante!
Ah,
finally!
Harder than the bird.
What's this?
Can I jump on top of this thing?
Oh, no, that's where the platform landed.
What's this?
At least we still have the Orb of Confusion.
What's that?
There's something written.
The King of Avalon shall turn the Wheel of Destiny and take the story to the Beginning Land.
Wheel of Destiny?
Oh my gosh, we just have the Wheel of Destiny!
A round plate resembling a Destiny's repetitive cycle.
I just have all this stuff.
Yeah, we did it!
What did I get?
A B!
Not bad, for forgetting the controls a little bit.
Save.
Nice.
Alright, next mission, baby!
Mission 16, Nightmare of Darkness.
Unravel the mystery of the Staff of Hermes.
Shall we power up?
Oh my gosh, I love Air Raid.
Thank you guys for telling me to get it.
I don't think we would have been able to beat Big Ol' Bird Brain over there without it.
Vortex up with them enemies.
There's also Ifrit.
I can't get any more Orbs.
Or even Blue Orbs.
Can I get some Yorbs?
Vortex's Air Raid Stinger.
No way!
Save for Orbs.
Inferno is great for ground control.
Inferno.
Oh, I need a lot of money for that though.
Create a wildfire and burn everything with it.
Oh, I see.
These are for when I pull my Devil Trigger.
And these are for normal.
Okay.
For now, let's just continue onward.
Mission started!
Oh my gosh!
We got a Blorb!
They just gave it to us.
Wait, what was the Blorb for?
Oh, the Blorb is when you collect more Blorb.
You...
Increase your health.
I remember.
More life, yeah.
I remember now.
So what do I do with this wheel?
Unravel the mystery of the staff...
Where is that?
Oh, oops.
Back to the courtyard?
Okay.
The door is right there.
Wow, I thought the Colosseum would be way more dramatic.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Screw it.
Yay, air raid!
Is it here?
Where they are guarding me over to?
I don't remember what's in here.
Okay, hold on.
It's very spoopy in here, it is.
The staff... Okay, so we went in there.
I've been in there.
I think I gotta go where the...
These are...
Calling for me.
The cows.
I hear pigs.
I hear the whole farm up in this tower.
Where the hell am I?
Wait a second, this is where I fought...
Oh no, nevermind.
Wait a second, maybe I went to the wrong place.
Oh,
it is the right place.
Okay, sorry.
It's a little confusing.
What's this?
Devil star!
Nice, take it.
What's this?
There is a message carved in the circle.
The wheel of destiny shall guide you to the land of the beginning.
It's about to get more confusing.
Okay, I might require some assistance, everybody.
We'll see how brained I can be today.
I didn't get much sleep.
Oh my gosh, in my head, all I was doing was playing...
Like, while I was trying to sleep...
My brain was so active.
I just kept playing Faith.
Like, in my brain.
I was making up levels of Faith, since I played Faith.
Last night...
And so I was just like, okay, now I gotta go fight this boss, so I can get this ending.
And I was like, oh my... I could not get it out of my brain.
It was so annoying.
And I'd be like, okay, focus on the audiobook I put on.
Which I put on something about mummies.
It was like a documentary on mummies.
And I could not focus on it at all.
I don't know anything about the mummies.
Someone is snoring in my ear.
Okay.
Oh, that's my own shadow.
Where are we anyway?
The door has disappeared.
It must be the work of dark evil powers.
Is there a door here?
There is a door there?
Are we at the...
Oh yeah, we are at the main entrance room.
Wow, can I still get the orb that was up there?
That I missed all that time ago?
Oh, I saw a blorb.
Oh, wait, it's over this way.
What's the music?
Why is it like that?
Blorb fragment.
Oh, we made a whole blorb.
Lucky us.
Okay, awesome.
Why is it so spooky?
Am I supposed to... I feel like I'm supposed to just run.
What did I do?
What did I just...
Uh-oh.
I created a bat.
It's my child now.
I met Eredor.
Yeah, that's so awesome.
Oh, double trigger?
Oh, I can't double trigger.
Hey, you can't use my own stuff on me.
No, no, stop it.
Stop it!
Stop!
I think I did it.
The stinger stung lock.
A classic.
Wait, what door was that?
Oh, I hear things.
I hear things.
Okay, that's the red one.
This one?
Blue one.
Oh, come on, again?
Oh my god, there's...
Wait, I double triggered though.
Oh my god, what is happening?
I'm not hearing very much right now, you guys.
That was pretty bad.
Wait, what the hell?
Oh my god!
They don't stop coming.
Oh my god, please.
Ridiculous.
That's a lot of rorbs.
Yeah!
We got so many rorbs.
Good, go us.
Now we have two doors.
Oh, just kidding.
There used to be a door here.
Wait, is there still anything up here?
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Oh my gosh, it's so spooky in here now.
Go in through here?
Oh, it was kind of a door.
It was a thing.
Oh my god.
It was a thing that I had to attack.
It was like a little elevator.
I remember.
Oh gosh.
Wait, where the hell am I supposed to go?
I don't remember where the thing of Hermes was.
I remember this was a little library room.
It still exists.
Is there anything in here?
Besides the power-up?
It's not.
More rorbs.
Why do you attack the elevator?
You just gotta.
You have to attack the thing to open up the elevator.
I remember.
We're halfway there to getting Inferno.
Alright.
Yeah, I remember.
My memory is not going that much.
Is this level 2?
Wait, should we actually?
Don't let him get a little word in.
Don't even let them get a word in.
Oh my gosh.
There was a door.
Wait, all these doors are disappearing.
But the painting of the middle-aged man stays.
Yeah, I think I have... I think I can't upgrade my stinger anymore.
Oh my god.
Party.
Oh wait, I can kill him.
Hold on.
Unless the door was further down here.
No, there was a door.
Trippy place.
This game looks fun.
It's very fun actually.
There was the door here!
Oh my gosh, everything has changed.
This is where I fought the spider.
Wait, what's that?
Hold on, let's look around first before we activate anything.
This is pretty.
This is... wet?
Oh god, what?
What do you mean, oh god?
What do you mean?
Be careful?
Of the wet?
Of the water?
Nightmares?
You're scaring me.
If I touch it, what happens?
Wait, what's...
The door won't budge an inch!
Okay.
I'm just exploring real quick.
What's about to happen?
I don't even know.
I'm scared.
You guys are freaking me out.
You guys are freaking me out!
I guess I start attacking this.
Oh, it lit up?
Okay.
Oh, they all light up.
I think.
Wait, what?
Hit it with the sword?
Check the puddle.
Save?
Oh gosh, you guys are scaring me.
Wait, how many?
I have two yorbs.
How do I save again?
Oh, here.
I'm going to save.
It won't let me jump on it.
Do I need to be doing this?
Oh, woah.
There's a strong surge of evil coming from the puddle of water.
There's a voice in my head saying something.
One who knocks on the gate to the underworld shall borrow the strength from the blue stout.
The blorb?
Oh boy.
Oh
my god, what's happening?
I
can get grorbs here though.
Those
are a big deal.
I can't see.
Where's the other skelly men?
Oh, there's the big skelly.
Oh, there he is!
Wait, what the hell?
Oh my god, no, this is actually how it is.
Oh shoot!
Oh my god, no, no way.
This sucks!
I don't want to fight this guy again!
Oh my gosh, please.
Please!
Dante, run!
I got him.
Again!
Wait, am I going to fight the griffon too?
What is this?
Oh wait, can I leave?
Oh!
Do I have to get sent to hell?
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
Wait, get out of there Dante.
Is it?
Ok, hold on.
Oh my god.
Please leave me alone!
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
Oh my god, ouchie, ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
This thing is killing me bad.
Oh my gosh!
Please!
Oh my god, please let me move!
Oh my god, no way.
This is so bad.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
Get me back to hell please!
Oh shoot.
And it heals!
Or did it heal?
Oh my god.
This stupid ass thing.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
This is so... Oh my god.
Green star where?
I don't know where.
It was so hard.
NT.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, so...
Is the strat to go to hell?
And then... or is it...
I feel like I did the most damage when he ate me up and then I got sent to hell.
One of the hardest bosses in this game.
The hell is slower.
Okay.
It did a big damage though.
It did big damage when I went the first time.
It only works once?
I see, I see.
It's
own DT once it absorbs enough.
How do I stop it from absorbing it?
Well, it was.
It was when I turned it.
Yeah, I noticed that.
It was just sometimes it was hard for me to aim.
If red, you think it would be better?
At least the save spot is close.
Until we run out of yorbs.
RB.
Why?
Okay.
You saved in here.
It's fine.
No, that's the thing.
If I run out of yorbs, I have to do the chapter all over again.
It doesn't matter where I saved.
It doesn't matter.
You guys, the yorbs are your saves basically.
For those who don't know how it works, we only have two yellow orbs and I just ran out of one.
Yeah, this game is absolutely evil.
If red on the orb, okay.
Okay, let's try it.
Wait, why isn't it letting me switch?
Oh, here we go.
Yes.
I'm just seeing right now for what's happening.
It doesn't last very long.
Oh, it's still going.
Yeah, okay.
Hold on.
Give me one second, guys.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Sorry, I got a message I got to reply to.
We're good.
All good.
Alright, here we go.
Can I skip this?
These guys suck so bad.
Oh my god, please.
No.
Ouch.
Oh my
god.
I think we're going to the underworld.
Okay.
Why
are they suddenly so difficult?
Hi!
Where is my grorb?
You cheap!
Hello?
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Where is my grorb?
You promised me!
I got no grorb.
This is messed up.
Oh my god.
Please leave me alone.
Punch!
Just non-stop punch!
Punch and kick!
Punch!
Oh my god.
Ouchie, ouch.
Guys, this is not looking so good.
Guys, I'm losing so much.
Oh, DT, thank you.
I lost so much health.
Where is my double jump?
Why is it not allowing me to anymore?
Wait, why actually is it not allowing me to double jump anymore?
That's weird.
I
don't think I'm good at using it for it, you guys.
I don't think I'm good at using it for it.
I don't think... I think I haven't used it enough to where it's like...
Comfortable for me.
Oh, double jump is for Alistair only?
That's why.
Oh my god.
Okay.
You have to buy it with him too.
That's crazy.
Guys, it really helps with me.
Get it away from me, you suckers!
We're going to hell!
I don't like it.
I don't like...
I don't
like it.
That
last time...
Wait, we're not on the spider yet.
Where are you?
Just one more hit!
Come here!
We got so many rorbs, guys.
I wonder if I can save even though I don't have any yorbs left.
Just so I can keep my number of rorbs and all.
What's my health at?
Alright, here we go.
Wait, oh he's not...oh shit.
Nevermind.
Okay, nice!
Nice!
Oh
my god.
Ouch!
Got a bravo.
Alright.
Oh I need
the...oh shit.
Oh shit.
Come on!
Just a little bit more!
Oh shoot.
We did it!
Nice!
I didn't need the other orb.
Ugly.
Holy moly.
Good riddance.
Yeah, good riddance to you slimy poo-poo.
There's a...oh.
Please no more.
Okay.
Is that the end?
Oh come on.
I'm like shaking.
I'm like shaking from...
From that...
Okay.
When's the end of the chapter?
Oh come on.
Don't do this to me.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
What's this?
Nothing.
Alright.
The things.
It's reacting to the growing evil surge of the darkness.
Shall I use the staff of errors?
Yes.
Hermes.
What is that?
Oh the bedroom.
Oh.
Choose carefully.
Fast travel.
Left or right?
For what?
Unravel the mystery.
Okay.
Flip a coin.
Eenie meenie miney mo, catch a tiger by it's toe.
If he hollers, let him go.
My mom said to pick the very worst one.
And you are it!
Yippee!
Night terror.
Survive an encounter with nightmare.
Yeah, I felt that.
I felt that nightmare.
You know what?
Whatever.
I'll take it.
It's because I used two yorbs, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Save.
Please.
Thank you.
Hopefully I made the right choice.
Carded Memento.
Slash away at the dragon.
And enter the court with the quicksilver.
What the hell does this mean?
You guys, I can get Inferno.
Wait, so is...
I don't even see anything.
Let's double jump here.
I joined at a good time.
Maybe I should stick with Alistair here too, maybe.
Inferno is the equivalent of Air Hike.
Oh, it doesn't get double jump.
Oh, I thought people were saying that I would have to buy double jump on Ifrit as well.
Okay.
That's kind of lame.
Can I get a boar?
I could buy him another yorb.
But everyone tells me that buying yorbs is a scam.
I think having to buy anything is a scam.
Oh, it's DMC3.
Everybody is getting their games all confused and then you tell me the wrong information.
Buy a blorb.
Blorb and porb.
I'll buy them both, baby.
I have to slash away at a dragon.
Or something.
Okay.
No rorbs?
Cheap.
Cheapo.
Here we go.
What do you mean baseball?
That was easy.
Yeah, give me all your rorbs.
Give me all your rorbs.
I gotta get my money's worth.
Okay.
Baseball.
I'm going.
See what baseball is all about.
Oh, I think I heard the dragon.
What is going on?
Okay.
Why didn't this one open too?
Things
are getting mighty spooky here you guys.
Is that the dragon?
It's Psycho Mantis.
That was so unfair.
Holy cow.
I'm not afraid to use this on you.
Where am I at anyway?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Oh my gosh.
They hit like craziness.
Oh my god.
These are not just normal guys you guys.
These guys are crazy.
I can't see anything.
Bravo.
Yeah.
We got one.
We got two.
Crazy.
Absolutely.
Hey, the door disappeared.
I
know where the money is hidden.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
You son of a bitch.
Who the hell has fire?
Stop it.
Leave me alone.
More grime.
Ouch.
Another grime would be mighty appreciated here.
Die.
Stay down.
What was down here anyway?
Am I in a maze?
Where is the dragon?
What's this?
The door went open.
There is a round hole in the center.
Show the gem with the moonlight.
Moonlight.
Grorb or Gorb?
Grorb.
Oh yeah, Grorb.
Sorry.
I keep saying Gorb.
The Grorb.
Green orb.
Grorb.
I think I'm shooting at invisible enemies.
Nevermind.
That was not an invisible enemy.
Here is the dragon.
I can't see though the dragon.
Oh my goodness.
Where?
What the hell?
A strange power has confronted me.
I've got to find a way to defeat the dragon.
Okay.
I'll come over this way.
Gaze into the light.
And that gave me a Blorb.
How nice.
Okay.
Calm down, guy.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
It's literally a fossil.
I'm not trying to be rude, but he is actually a fossil.
I have to find a way to kill this fossil.
What the hell?
Are you kidding me?
How did that hit?
This is a dragon.
Is this what you meant by baseball?
Okay.
Take me out to the ball game.
Take me out to the crowd.
Buy me some pizza and crackerjacks.
I don't care if I never come back.
Home run, baby.
Root, root, root for the home team.
If they don't win, it's a shame.
Okay.
I see the platforms.
I see what I've got to do.
This went lower, but it didn't do anything.
I'm seeing if there is any delicious grorbs.
But none seem to be about.
Good job, Dante.
I can't see my depth perception.
Okay.
I made it.
Oh my gosh, that's my own shadow.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Okay, nice.
I'm too afraid.
Don't trust me.
Next one, next one.
Okay, next one, next one.
It's a device to gather moonlight.
I don't have anything to collect the moonlight.
A stone, perhaps?
Perhaps.
We need the stone.
Wait, it didn't pull the crank.
What crank?
Wait, what crank?
We need the stone that will... Is it in these little rooms?
What's...
These little rooms.
None of them are open.
Make your streams of healthy feel happy.
Thank you.
Thank you, Yoshi.
I'm so happy to hear that.
Thank you.
Ignore chat and look around.
That's what I'm doing.
I'm looking around, you guys.
I'll figure it out.
So there is a... Oh, a lady.
Oh la la.
Oh, what's this?
There is something written.
The confronter of the path.
Pluto's dragon.
Prove your bravery with your sword and the dragon will fall in its own flame.
Oh,
I can be faster.
I was like cranking like an old man.
Collected the moonlight.
Look at all these ladies.
Hot mamas.
How did I miss this when I first came in?
I think I was more concerned about, you know...
The dragon that was attacking me and...
All that fun stuff.
We were more a little concerned about, you know.
Oh, dang it.
Sorry, you guys.
I did it once and now I'll never be able to do it again.
Lightning!
I don't need no lightning.
Why does it sound like the dragon is still here with us?
Okay.
We've got the quicksilver.
A crystal ball filled with mercury.
The mercury has lunar powers that will open sealed doors.
Thank you, I guess, guys, for telling me about the baseball.
Griffo!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Because I missed the stone that explained the baseball.
I missed the stone that explained it.
I was so concerned with the dragon itself.
Go away.
Wait, is there any... Oh, nope.
That door is gone.
Nice!
This side!
Blow up!
The door won't open.
There's a round hole in the center.
Quicksilver, yes!
We made it.
No, no, no.
Please, no.
I like that.
Those are some fancy moves you got.
No!
Oh my god, my eyes.
Oh, he took off his mask.
Oh no, he's hot.
Oh shit.
I'm just gonna devil trigger and immediately start blasting him.
Oh, I'm taking hits.
Why am I the one taking hits?
All
over again, please.
Sir, please.
Why do I have to fuck you again?
Mundus!
Not Mundus, but you serve Mundus.
Oh my god.
Stop blocking my attacks!
Holy moly.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it.
Okay, when all the swords happen, maybe don't be up in the air, I guess.
You can start again from a save point.
When did I last save?
Oh no.
Okay.
Well, I would have to do this all over again anyway.
Messed up.
So messed up.
No, we're gonna have to do this stage all over again.
But I didn't save, so I didn't get any of my roars.
Can you aim for the guy that's there on the ground?
Oh man.
Yeah, I noticed he was blocking my air raid.
When he stopped blocking it, I would attack.
But I noticed he was doing that too.
Definitely noticed that.
Did I
save before the dragon?
That would have been awesome.
Oh wait.
Oh no!
I have to do these guys again too!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is so evil!
These guys suck!
I wonder.
Hold on.
If I change to this because it's a fire weapon, would that be better?
Let's see.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Run!
Run Dante!
Dante, run!
Oh my god.
Can you at least get a hit in, man?
Can you do anything?
Oh!
Wait, I think I... I'm about to die.
Oh my god, I'm about to die.
This is me not getting a lot of practice in with him.
Oh my gosh, so evil.
Oh wait,
I'm gonna have to fight them again.
Remember to smiley.
Oh, if there were any spoilers, you guys...
Please, this is my first time playing, so no spoilers on stuff!
Take
care of this guy right now, but I will.
I blasted him.
Please.
Did I die?
Wait, where am I?
Why was I not doing any damage?
That was so weird.
Why was I not attacking?
I got strung up.
Nice gorb.
Oh.
This strung me up.
I need to
heal more.
I don't think this is the run, you guys.
Oh my god.
I don't think this is the run.
I guess we'll see.
Oh, ok.
Strike.
Oh, and then it appears again.
I should really offer some gorbs before this part.
Or before the fight.
You know?
I should offer some gorbs.
But they don't.
They're so rude.
I will save so we can at least keep our rorbs.
How many rorbs do I even have?
We have 2,500.
I do have... I actually do have some, like, things for healing.
I think?
Or maybe I don't.
I have a devil star.
Can you imagine if this worked?
Ugh.
Ok.
I guess maybe I...
We can farm the puppet hall for gorbs.
I think I have to.
But I'm still... I'm nervous because...
Oh my god.
I'm too good at this now.
I'm nervous because my health... I haven't been doing a very good job.
I haven't been doing a very good job.
I don't know where... if there is a shop.
Maybe... Oh, nice.
Oh, that gorb did wonders.
Maybe I can farm these guys a little bit more.
Where is he?
I heard him.
Or I'm going crazy.
At least it doesn't take much to get back to this point, I suppose.
Ok.
Yes.
This boss is decently hard, so don't feel bad.
But everyone said the nightmare was the most difficult.
Let's go.
Ok, let's just...
This music is crazy.
Ouch!
Perry!
Oh my god, where did he go?
Oh my god, this is so evil, please!
Ouch!
I'm going to double check.
He's huge!
This guy is huge!
Huge!
Ginormous!
Oh my god, wait.
I didn't mean to do that.
Guys, this is not the run.
I can't see!
I'm not trying to turn into this guy.
I'm just trying to...
I'm trying not to... I don't want to turn into the flying guy.
I keep... Because I keep holding it down to aim.
Camera angle is the real boss.
Actually, though.
Oh...
I feel like I...
Use Ifrit instead because I keep accidentally turning into the flying guy.
Holy water works on him?
Don't get my hopes up.
I need more than one person to say... I need at least 50 people to say that.
Before I believe it.
It will do damage.
Does a ton of damage.
Holy water is what I always use here.
Okay.
I have a few bits of holy water.
But because I keep turning into the flying guy and that is not effective against him...
I wonder if I should be Ifrit.
If I should do this instead.
But I can only really level up.
I can't even get Infernal.
Let's try again.
And try and get more orbs.
And then I can maybe...
Maybe...
Eventually...
Get the...
Maybe eventually get the...
The...
The Infernal.
Do you get more orbs with killing things in more style?
Or is it just gotcha?
Yes, I figured.
I figured.
Holy water does good damage if you don't miss.
That's the other thing.
I guess I'll try Ifrit here.
Wait, what's the other one?
He has two.
Why in Dante's back?
Dante's face.
That's what I tried though.
Maybe... Hold on, the camera angle is a little weird.
That was Dante's back and this is Dante's front.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Holy moly!
Yeah, lizard!
Charge your punches.
How do I do that?
I just like, hold it?
Let's turn back to this since it works here.
Wow, that was so easy.
Oh, sorry.
My style points.
Oh yeah, we got some crazy numbers there.
Okay, I'll try not to use my gun at all.
Cool!
Is there anyone else?
Full health.
Everything is good good.
Let's wait for him to do the first shot.
Alright.
Take me out to the ball game.
Take me out to the crowd.
Buy me some pizza and crackers.
I always gotta get hit by one.
You're out!
Good timings, nevermind.
Hey!
There was a timing.
Old man Dante trying to turn this crank.
Come on Dante!
You got this!
Oops.
Oh
no!
I knew I was going crooked.
Let's double jump.
It's just way easier to make it.
And jump!
Quick silver.
I'm scared of this guy.
Shadow on the pillar startles me.
Me too.
Every time.
Let's overwrite.
I'll do it right before I get to the door too though.
Since we get some more rorbs in this hallway.
I keep forgetting.
Okay.
What mission was this again?
Oh, whoopsie.
Sorry.
Yay!
Oh,
over here.
Cool!
Is that it?
Is that all of them?
17?
Oh!
That was not all of them.
Oh my gosh!
There's more of them!
I think they're coming through the portal.
Ouch!
You better give me a grorb now mister.
I was full health!
You asshole!
Thank you.
I think there's some more rorbs back here.
Ask and you shall receive everybody.
Save so we keep our rorbs.
And we're at 2-9.
Almost 3,000.
Time for cheese.
How do I cheese?
Oh wait, I was gonna...
Oh wait, well...
No, I think I should.
I think I should switch.
Alright, let's go baby!
Okay.
Stop taunting me!
Oh, it opens up his defense?
Oh, come on.
Shoot!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh my god.
Oh no!
What is this combo you do?
No way man!
I barely...I can't even get him to halfway health.
I can't even get him to halfway health.
Oh gosh.
Oh my gosh, the amount of damage he does is crazy.
And I'm not used to his moves yet.
This is gonna take me forever.
I'm not used to his moves yet.
Can we power up Ifrit?
Maybe I should do kick level 2.
This is why kick is forward.
But I wanna maybe wait for Inferno.
And I didn't even use the holy water.
He's a critical boss for the story so they make him mad hard.
Yeah, I can kinda tell he's a little important.
Kick level 2 is good.
It'll waste all...or not waste, but it'll use all my...
Almost all my roars.
How much is like a...what is it?
Not holy water.
Because like I said, I have a couple of those, I'm pretty sure.
It's vital star.
Wait, untouchable?
Is that any good?
Should we become untouchable?
How long does that last even?
Hi Batboy!
Thanks for the gift.
I honestly didn't know you could cheese him.
What is the cheese?
You guys, what's the cheese?
Can you tell me the cheese?
30 seconds.
Holy water?
Oh, just the holy water is the cheese?
Does he have any iframes like after you holy water?
Or could you spam it?
Johnny, thanks for the 5 gifted.
The cheese.
Pepperjack.
I guess I should get some vital stars.
Oh, sorry.
A singular vital star.
You cannot hold anymore of this item.
Gabe, I only have one.
What do you mean?
I can still get kick level too.
I got it.
It takes up too much space.
What's up big boy?
Yeah, I have three holy waters.
So I think we'll be okay for now.
Wait, what do I have?
Okay, good.
We kickin' boys.
We kickin'.
Hopefully.
Hopefully I can kick well.
Hopefully I can do the kick.
Wow, shooting him and attacking him like that gave me the same amount.
Oh well.
I'm not salty or anything.
I don't know why I feel like this gives me something when I know it doesn't.
To the outside!
We kickin'.
I'm still kickin'.
We get
him in the...
Let's switch back to...
Yeah.
R3 to switch the sword.
Oh that's right.
I forgot I can do it like that.
Thank you for reminding me.
Grab my rorbs.
Oh my god!
Give me a rorb for that please.
Oh my gosh.
Screw it.
I'm double triggering now.
I don't care anymore.
Oh, I got him.
They don't stop coming.
Oh my gosh, they are all spotted.
So much right here.
Holy moly.
Shoot!
Fine.
You know what?
Yeah, you want a piece of this?
I did so well with the other guys.
And then I just...
Whatever.
With these guys...
I think I get like... What's the word?
Not cocky, but like overly confident.
Because there's this kind of dudes in the hallway.
Oh.
You weren't done.
So cocky.
No!
I think cocky would be me being like...
But I'm just like...
It's like a little... Oh, get out of my way.
Little guys.
It's fine.
Get complacent.
Sure, sure.
Hold on, I gotta turn on my fan.
It's toasty in my room.
OK.
Easy.
I'm gonna be a master at this section and this section alone.
Go!
Go Dante!
Turn!
It's so...
It's so silly.
It's so like stiff when you turn it.
I don't know why I don't double jump there.
That was close.
This checkpoint placement is brutal.
Yeah, it's not very kind, is it?
I have 700 rorbs.
OK.
Yeah, it's not very kind.
It's fine.
Yeah, I'm just gonna take out these guys right quick.
And then save.
Nice.
We'll save.
Well, I guess it doesn't matter where we save.
Cause it doesn't really matter.
It doesn't really matter.
OK.
I'm gonna think of... I'm gonna think of chapter 17.
Wait, I almost said number 15 like the Burger King foot lettuce.
I'm gonna think of...
I'm gonna think of chapter 17 for the rest of my afterlife.
OK.
Holy water!
And I have vital star.
For the holy water...
If I'm like right on top of him, will that hit him, right?
Don't miss.
Like, I don't think I've used it enough to really know how it works.
He does need to be close.
OK.
Reminder about quick switch.
Thank you.
As long as he doesn't teleport.
OK.
Double star is just what will recover my double trigger, so that will be good too, obviously.
But for damage to him...
Oh shoot!
Oh wait, so if I do it like now...
Holy water!
Holy water, man!
Oh shoot.
Oh, wait.
Vital star.
And then...
Let it recover.
Wait, is he about to teleport?
Yes.
Double star.
Shoot.
Wait, wait.
Hold on.
Oh shoot!
No, no, no.
Holy water!
Wait, is this phase 2?
Is this phase 2?
No way.
A win is a win.
Wait a second.
That's our necklace.
That's the one that our mom gave us.
Wait, why did...Did he take our necklace?
He's our mom!
Oh my gosh!
I've always wanted a brother.
It's...
Virgil!
It was our brother!
But we thought he was dead.
Yes, my master.
Oh my god!
Yippee!
We finally got through it.
A win is a win, baby.
Shut up, game.
Boss bonus, baby.
Don't look at the score.
Don't care about it.
We don't care.
A win is a win.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe it was our brother.
I thought it was our...not dad.
Spirit stone elixir.
You were thinking it was dad.
You thinking it was dad wasn't too far off.
Yeah, basically.
Thanks for four months, mustache man.
Throw the philosopher's egg into the fire and transform it into a spirit stone.
They just say things in this game.
The combined form of Dante's pendant and Dark Knight's pendant.
It allows entry into the underworld.
Oh my gosh, I'm Devil May Cry.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I'm basically Sparda.
Oh!
I am Sparda!
It's the true form of the Force Edge.
The sword wielded by the legendary Dark Knight Sparda.
It's loud.
Oh my gosh.
Yippee!
Wait, so if I...
Oh wow.
I want to play with it.
Wait, how do I...
How do I play with it?
It has no DT though.
It's kind of lame.
Hold on, I'm checking around.
Oh wow, my throne.
I see no... Do I need any grorbs?
Oh, I don't actually.
Here we go.
Oh, the other side opened up.
Nice.
But was there anything else in here?
I destroyed the chair earlier.
It's basically a beefed up Alistair.
Oh no!
Wait, oh no!
Grorb.
Oh gosh.
Ew, this water is nasty and disgusting.
What is that?
Oh, gross.
Oh my god, why did you do this?
Wait, can I...
How do I... Wait, how do I attack again in the water?
Shouldn't it like...
How do I attack again in the water?
Shoot?
Oh, is it just shoot?
Oh, there we go.
I
feel like these are traps.
What?
Should I follow the roar?
But the roar bled me here.
Oh, this looks like a dirty, ugly, nasty room.
Probably with a secret.
I'm kind of a genius, you guys.
Don't ever doubt my genius.
How did she know?
Lots of roar in here.
Golly.
Good thing we don't need to have to breathe.
Ew!
These guys are really nasty.
Oh my god.
Look at that form though.
Girl, we love a curvaceous mama.
That's me.
You got a nice bod.
Why is there so many heads out here?
Why are there so many... Are we going to the underworld?
The underworld is... Oh no no.
This might be the worst part ever.
Anyway.
Loot, please.
Classic bad underwater.
I still hear more.
Are more of them coming?
Let's just get out of here.
Freedom!
We are now a rail shooter.
Congrats.
OK.
Why do I feel like I've seen this area before?
Oh, there is lighting.
No!
Why did I do that?
I just made it terrible for myself.
Come on Dante, why are you so lazy?
You can't even just...
You can't just use your legs?
Come on.
Just run for it.
It's not that big of a deal.
Oh man.
Oh gosh.
I knew I would have to.
I knew I would have to, otherwise why would it be there?
But I just wanted to believe I didn't have to.
Maybe like to here works?
Oh yeah, there are doors here and stuff.
Nice.
I think this is good, maybe for now.
Because there is a door here.
Let's see.
Maybe up here?
Do I have to go all the way to the top?
We are exploring everybody.
What do you want?
He says that way.
Thank you sir.
That way.
Just a tiny little bit.
Oh we got...
A thing.
Oh the philosopher's egg.
A material used in alchemy.
Not to be mistaken for the philosopher's stone.
Nobody likes that anymore.
Everybody goes for the egg.
What was the mission again?
I supposed to put this into the fire.
Wait, is that the fire that I saw in that door?
Wait, what's over here?
A whole lot of nothing.
Please, don't...
Wait, oh no.
Am I gonna have to swim again?
No Dante.
Dante, are you gonna have to swim again I think?
Oh ok, good, good, good.
Or wait, where was the door?
Egg!
Thanks for the first super chat!
Thank you so much!
Egg, it's you the philosopher's...oh there it is.
The philosopher's egg.
Egg Mansion.
Alright.
There's the fire.
What else is around here?
This area looks mighty suspicious.
Oh no.
No.
No, wait.
No, please.
Also, don't mistake for philosopher's legacy.
So true.
No, nightmare!
There's something engraved.
Those who seek the truth shall put the egg in the basket.
As a philosophy student I can confirm eggs are very important to us.
And shall warm it slowly with care.
It will become a blue stone and the landmark to the rough roads.
Shall I?
Yes.
It may take some time for it to transform.
Oh god!
Why!?
I don't have a devil trigger!
Please!
Please jump up on the back!
Get up on the Hydra's back!
Oh my god.
Wait, am I going to hell?
Oh no!
It's the Gryphon!
It's the Gryphon though.
I don't want to fight that guy.
I can't believe he sent the Gryphon to hell.
That's crazy.
Oh my gosh.
I want to devil trigger.
It's kind of messed up that I can't!
Get up on the Hydra's back!
I'm going to corner you guys.
Oh, ouchie ouch.
Please.
Please, can I attack you?
Oh my god.
Oh, it's doing big damage though.
Oh no!
Oh, ouchie ouch.
OK, I can't dodge through here.
Like it appeared to be able to do.
Oh gosh.
Please.
OK,
cool.
That was a nice little break we had from the nightmare.
Good job.
No DT, but big damage.
I wonder though if it would be better to DT...
With this... With the nightmare.
Like, you know the...
Oh wait, I gotta...
Oh my gosh.
God, he is absolutely destroying me.
Oh my god.
These things suck so bad.
Hey, ouchie ouchie ouch.
I'm not taking so much damage actually.
So...
Keeping nice and bright in here.
Big rorbs.
Transformation is complete.
We need to vomit, Ivo.
Why are you talking?
Why do we need to vomit, Ivo?
A strange voice from the transformed stone is echoing inside my head.
I am the first key to opening the gate of the underworld.
The second key resides in a mirror dimension.
Oh no, will everything be backwards?
Elixir.
It is the metamorphic form of the philosopher's legacy egg.
You can unseal the spells of the mirror.
Sorry.
Good night.
Fight nightmare a second time and prevail.
Oh, I did.
What's my score?
B for badass.
How many chapters were there?
26 or so?
How long have I been streaming for?
Hold on.
Oh, there we go.
23.
Oh shoot.
So we have 18?
5 more!
Let's go.
Enter the corrupted world.
Open the gate to the underworld.
Oh yay!
I wish I could get some stuff for the sword though.
Wish I could get some stuff for the sword.
The last few were short?
Oh really?
Would you say I've already faced the toughest battles?
The toughest bosses?
Or do you think like the final boss will be really hard?
No?
Final boss is pretty hard too?
Oh god.
I figured it would be like that.
Final boss is gonna take you a few.
The end of the game is easily the worst bosses.
We got this guys.
I believe in us.
Is there anything else in here?
Anything exciting?
No?
What is this circle room for anyway?
We have all this fancy stuff.
I think I already jumped around here.
Yeah, ok.
Let's just go in.
There we go!
What would be the weapon you would use for the final boss?
I know I'm not there yet, but I'm just curious.
What would you say?
So we are trying to open the door to the underworld?
Is that what we are doing?
Open the gate.
Sparda?
Ok.
Oh I think I need to go down here.
Sparda.
There it is.
Or something related to it.
The elixir is responding strongly to the other painting.
Oh finally!
I was curious what the other painting was.
I'm glad they at least give you the option.
Oh, smileys.
I won't look.
I won't look with your smileys.
No spoilers guys.
No spoilers.
I know I asked questions, but...
Blur fragment.
And then also, what is this?
Untouchable!
Let's go.
Uh oh.
Why are they giving me these?
Why are you giving me these?
I have 3000.
It's not bad.
Maybe I should get some more holy water and stars and stuff.
People really can't help themselves.
It's ok.
I forgot to put a little thing in the chat that says no spoilers please.
Honestly, my fault.
It's alright.
It's all good though.
What's this way?
Nothing.
This way.
The doors vanished.
Oh, that's not a door anymore?
Ok.
Scary.
Wait, the doors vanished due to evil powers.
And this is where we got that lady who was crying.
We bring into the studio this morning one of the spooking rights activists, Minto.
Should I call you Minto?
Made Minto.
Thank you for coming here.
What?
The doors vanished due to evil powers.
Spooky.
Wait, what am I doing here then?
I just teleported here?
Oh my gosh, camera please.
What?
Spooky.
What is this?
Oh, the mirror is responding to the elixir.
And it's reflection is growing eerier.
Alright.
I forgot that that was a mirror because I couldn't see myself.
Oh, we are in the mirror dimension.
Oh, woah.
Oh, I didn't mean to...
Wait, hold on.
Let me look in there real quick.
You have not watched the Why Are You Giggling?
Oh, I did.
It's just you started that as if like...
As a bunch of other interviews start as.
Nightmare Beta.
A weapon formed in the underworld.
Collect all guns!
Oh my gosh, I got the achievement.
Here is the statue.
The Watcher of Time is just an illusion.
Orbs have no use here.
I got all the guns.
Can I use it?
Nightmare Beta.
Let's go.
What is this Metal Gear ass music right now?
Oh my god.
Oh guys, I think...
Oh, it's making me a little motion sick.
I'm not going to lie.
Oh, it's making me a little motion sickness.
Philosopher's Stone.
It is the key.
Wait, there is an actual Philosopher's Stone?
Where is the legacy?
It is the key to unlocking the gate of the underworld.
Ew.
Where am I jumping at?
Ew!
What are you doing?
Oh my god, it's becoming Jojo.
They put on the mask.
What does this mean?
Now it can stand?
It's becoming human?
What is happening?
Ok, I'm just going to ignore that guy for a second and take care of this guy.
Holy moly!
I
got that guy though.
Hold on.
I want the...
Yeah, give me...
I did?
Oh, he's still... Oh, he's blowing up.
Oh, ok.
Wow, big money baby.
Can I leave here please?
Wait, where is the door?
Is this the door?
That's not the door.
Where is the door?
Is this the door?
Oh, up?
Ok.
Oh my goodness, I can't see anything.
Ok, that's kind of an awesome shot though.
Oh,
up more.
Blorb!
No, we have to go back!
We have to go back!
We must grab the blorb.
Is it worth it?
Absolutely!
100%.
Maybe I...
Do I go up on this guy in the middle here?
You need air raid to get this one.
Oh, well.
I can just switch, right?
What's my thing?
Oh, what's my...
Yeah!
Oh wait, is that empty?
You were never able to get it?
Oh, you've never met someone as stubborn as a mint fronto.
When I want something...
I get it.
Sorry if this world is making you...
It's actually not so bad up here.
But in that little courtyard, it makes me super woozy.
Alright, let's see.
Also, it's like floating.
Oh gosh, standing still also makes me really woozy.
I don't want to use my devil star for this, you know?
Not for the blorb.
If I have to use air raid, maybe it's not worth it then.
Yeah, maybe it's not worth it.
But it's like a blorb fragment too.
Blorb is the best reason to use one, but it's probably a blorb fragment.
I'm stubborn, but I'm also frugal.
What if I like...
Have four D-stars?
Yeah, I could need all of them for...
For the final fight.
And I only have two out of four blorbs.
You will not use them?
There is no way else?
Come on Dante, just reach up.
Reach up with your arms, Dante.
I'm trying to get up on the tower.
Trust us Minto?
What am I trusting you with?
With my afterlife?
I don't know about that.
Dante does have a ledge grasp.
I know he does.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is the final boss.
Gotta use the star.
I'm too tall!
Now I'm angry.
Let me leave!
The final boss with Minto's depth perception.
Can you blame me?
This world is whack!
Wait, where the hell is the door anyway?
This world is whack, absolutely.
Where is the door?
I'm gonna throw up.
Oh god, please.
Same way you came in.
I don't remember where that was.
Is it over there?
Oh, I see it!
How do I get up there?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Hold on.
Oh, I think I'm gonna throw up, you guys.
Okay, I see where the door is, but I just gotta get through it.
Oh, please.
How do I get up there?
There's a hole you fell down to get to the door.
Oh, oh!
Okay, okay.
I thought that hole would bring me all the way to the bottom.
Okay, thank you.
I'm like squinting so I don't see the screen.
Okay.
Oops.
Oh, sorry Blorb.
Not today.
Oh gosh.
Hold on, I'm gonna go get some more water.
And maybe throw up.
I'll be right back.
Hold on.
Sorry about that.
I'm okay.
I didn't throw up.
I ate some chips.
I'm okay.
Oh my goodness.
I was like... I was like, am I gonna...
Am I gonna throw up?
But I didn't.
Okay.
See ya.
Stupid mirror world.
I never want to go back ever.
How much have you eaten today?
I've eaten five.
Wait, where do I go with this?
With my philosopher's stone.
It just says open the gate.
Okay, well...
Go across the bridge.
Back here?
Oh man.
I forget that it doesn't kill you.
Why is my thing shaking though?
Are we okay?
Oh no.
Wait.
What's this?
Okay.
Who's coming for me next?
You two?
Little skellies.
You think you're so spooky?
You think you're so creepy scary?
Skull issue?
Whatever works, works you guys.
I think that works better.
Surge of evil is reacting to the power of the elixir.
No, no.
No, no, god no.
It's starting to activate.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
No.
Okay.
His powers are unknown.
Does this use my devil trigger as a thing?
Maybe I should go back to my grenade launcher.
Yes, okay.
I'm gonna go back to my grenade launcher.
I don't use it so much with this guy, but...
Oh.
No, no, no.
No guys, I can't do this.
It's so wobbly, you guys.
I don't think I can...
I've never gotten so motion sick from a game that wasn't VR.
Oh my god.
It's just for one area?
Okay.
I'm just gonna run.
Oh wait, where am I?
Wait, did I... I think I'm trapped.
Wait.
Let me out, please.
Let me out.
My hair is stuck.
Oh there!
Dante, oh my god, thank goodness.
What is this?
Oh wait, I think I put the thing in here, right?
The evil darkness is whirling with its mouth open.
This must be the gate of the underworld.
Exciting.
Shall I?
Yes, use the philosopher's stone, please.
Okay, okay.
I thought I had to fight anything.
We opened the gate!
Hi, cool Dante.
A bee!
Oh, thank goodness.
Wow, we have 4,300.
We're killing it, you guys.
Bee for barf, for real.
Bee for barf!
Mission 20, showdown with nightmare.
No!
Head to the place of sacrifice.
Where are you, nightmare?
Wow, we're in the underworld, you guys.
Exciting.
Okay.
Wow, it's all pulsing.
Wait.
Okay, nevermind.
Whose flesh is this?
I think I'm going to get YouTube banned.
Oh my god!
What's in here?
Oh shit.
I can change to...
You.
Why is an ice creature in hell?
Oh my god.
Nice.
D'oh!
What do you mean, d'oh?
Oh my gosh, the statue is here.
Hell is not only fire.
In my brain it is.
Sparda.
Should we buy anything?
I didn't buy anything just when coming in here, but...
We have a lot of money.
Well, actually, in Dante's Inferno, the deepest circle of hell is cold mint.
Oh god, it's like you don't read classic Italian poetry.
Oh my god.
Why would you say that, VTuber?
You ill...
Oh my god, it's disgusting.
You illiterate, unrefined creature.
You can't even read the classic...
Like Dante's Inferno.
Oh my gosh, look at the bodies even.
Cutscene.
Oh...
What's your name?
Tina!
Trish!
Oh no, I see the lights on the ground.
Oh my god.
The final showdown with the nightmare.
Nightmare.
Oh, she's behind...
I wish I could too.
Okay, shoot.
Please.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh my gosh, please, let me move!
No!
I have like barely two seconds.
Oh, the light went out already?
So fast.
Wait, what happened?
Ouch!
Roar!
Be a morb!
Oh my god.
Guys, this isn't looking so hot.
I don't think this is...
I don't think this is looking so hot!
Dante, don't save her, you'll become a simp.
Oh
my gosh!
Oh my gosh!
No, please!
Get the lights, get the lights before it can melt.
Okay.
Please, open up!
Oh
my god, oh my gosh, Dante.
I think I might have to switch.
I might have to switch, I think.
Alistair is better since he can use E.T.
I think so.
I was thinking that I could use the air raid.
At least.
Oh my gosh.
But I have none.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm
gonna...
I died.
I was gonna say, I'm gonna die!
Yes, please.
Okay.
Oh, icky.
I hate this guy so much.
Holy cow.
Okay, let's switch to...
different for now.
Since we know we're gonna get those guys coming up here.
Camera is really bad in this room.
Yeah.
Ouchy, ouch.
Oh, oh.
Got him, baby.
From what I recall, Nightmare is weak to the Nightmare Beta gun.
It has been a while and I never defeated it.
What?
What do you mean?
You mean like you never beat the game?
Nightmare resists the gun.
Oh.
Wait, which is it?
You got this basil phantom.
That's not my name!
Nightmare Beta sucks?
Oh.
I'm a star!
Okay, we're at full Devil Trigger, so...
Maybe this will be okay.
Oh, I meant to save.
Dang it.
I'll save now.
Ice Demon in Hell?
Actual Dante describes Elastric Flotel as a permanently frozen lake.
I'm gonna get, I'm gonna get um, actually with this, huh?
Come on!
There we go.
And...
I can't see anything!
Please!
Oh shoot, I forgot about the lights!
One, two, hi!
I'll
turn around, Dante, please!
Holy cow.
This sucks
so bad.
Wait, did we get him?
What's going on?
Trish!
What?
But you're hot!
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
No, no way.
No, no, no, god!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die here, I'm gonna die here, I'm gonna die here!
Please, please, please!
Oh my god, oh my god, no way.
Trish, you bitch!
Dante, do anything, please!
I'm trying to decide what items I wanna use.
If I Holy Water, even if his little thing's not out...
Holy Water only if Orb is out, I don't know if it's out.
I think it would be better to Devil Star.
Oh shoot.
Why?
Why did he regain life?
What?
That's so messed up!
Bitch!
Actually, hold on.
I will buy some health stuff.
I guess I'll buy another Devil Star since I have to use it.
Oh man!
I always untouchable that last bit.
I think I should, I think I should, honestly.
I thought about it, I thought about using it.
I don't know if I should Blorb or Plorb.
Plorb, plorb, plorb, plorb.
Plorb?
Plorb.
It's hard to say.
Plorb?
Plorb it is.
Nightmare and Trish.
Trish.
Trish!
Evil, evil, evil.
What an evil fight, actually.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, I'm not even using it.
I'm such an idiot.
I was like, why am I...
700.
I didn't mean to buy the Devil Star.
I didn't mean to buy the Devil Star, but now we have 5 of them.
Oopsie!
Ok, the other way is over here.
Let's change our weapon, back to Alistar.
No!
Stop, stop!
Turn around, please!
Stop, stop, stop!
Please, Dante!
Dante, hit this instead, you dummy!
He... I hate Dante.
I hate this auto-lock.
The auto-lock sometimes is the worst thing ever.
It might actually be the least best thing ever.
It's so awful.
Please, Dante.
Dante, Dante!
Where is it?
No!
Please.
Oh, I wasted it.
Oh my gosh.
No!
Guys, this is not the run.
This is so not the run.
Oh my god.
What the hell?
Stay away from me!
I think I should.
Don't absorb your orb!
Release your orb!
For me!
Oh shoot.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
I think I'm... I think I'm in hell.
How much of...
That's fine.
That's fine, I guess.
Why do the lights have to go out though?
I always forget the lights go out in that moment.
Wait, who am I about to fight in here?
Wait, what boss am I about to fight in here?
Oh gosh.
I guess I'm getting like my devil trigger.
No!
No, no, no!
I had a feeling.
I had a feeling it was going to be...
Oh shit.
Wait, this doesn't work on him.
Never mind.
Sorry, I forgot about the quick change.
Wait, why did I do that?
I'm... You guys, I'm such a...
I
am here.
It's because of this fucking guy!
If I reload, do I get to keep all my stuff?
Since I lost it all.
Like... Ok, ok, ok.
Ok, ok, ok.
I hate the nightmare!
In this room specifically!
Eh...
Nice.
Where is the other guy?
Wait, where is... Oh.
We
took him out.
These lizards are no problem.
Oh wait.
Oh, ok.
Hi.
Oh, that's safe.
So I can keep my rorbs at least.
Why, Tina?
Why?
Guys, this part is so tricky!
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
Wait, hold on.
Holy water!
I'm behind his back!
Oh no, he's going back into the loop.
Glurp, glurp, glurp, glurp, glurp, glurp, glurp, glurp, glurp.
Ouch, please.
Please!
Uh-oh, wait.
Wait, shoot.
Stop, stop, stop, Dante!
You have to hit this part first, Dante!
Don't you remember, Dante!
Don't you know!
Dante, don't you know!
Dante!
Oh my god, why isn't it coming down though?
Wait, no, no, please.
Ok.
No, no, no, please!
I'm trying to hit the menu!
Let me hit the menu!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Ok, ok, ok.
It heals, it heals, it heals.
If you want DT, you can't have any!
We did it!
Get out of here, Trish.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's still gonna save her.
Dante is such a gentleman.
I'm guessing that's the last time I have to fight the nightmare because, you know, he was so big and bad in that part, right?
That was the final boss, right guys?
Right?
It is the last...
Dante!
I never let a pretty girl die.
Yeah, get out of here.
Is she gonna cry?
She's a devil.
She might cry.
She might be like...
Wait, Trish came up with the nightmare?
You're crazy!
What kind of psycho makes that thing up?
I don't wanna see what my rank is.
I knew it.
Whatever.
I don't care.
You know the rules.
And so do I.
Wait, I saved, right?
Next mission!
D for Dante, everyone.
Living Cave.
Pulsate the heart and open the last gate.
Oh my gosh, you guys, we have just three missions left.
This one, 22, 23!
Hate this mission?
Oh, right.
Can I go through here?
Is this where I came from?
What is this?
Oh, this is where I came from.
Nothing else in here, right?
You know the rules.
Wait, how's my health?
OK, we're good.
Holy water!
Thank you!
I used mine.
Oh, what's in here?
Oh, it's the heart.
So I gotta pulsate it?
OK, hold on.
Where is it?
What's shooting?
I think there's a lot of things pulsating here.
I mean...
OK, what's in this room?
I can't go in yet?
Strange claws are blocking the entrance.
It's impossible to open, even with my strength.
Oh, but it opens up when I walk away.
OK, guess we gotta go in here.
Oh, that was so close!
Ouch!
Oh.
Is this timed?
Oh gosh.
I can't see!
Oh, it's not?
OK.
Run, run, run!
Jelly door.
What's here?
What's in here?
Oh my gosh.
OK, luckily this isn't like the mirror world.
Let's stay away from the tongues.
Oh, nevermind.
I think that was a dead end.
Just keep running.
Oh, it's this thing again.
Watch out!
It's exploding!
It's disgusting!
It's like firecrackers.
OK, I can't stand too still or else other things are gonna get me.
Got it.
We have little dune monsters and everything.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, watch out!
Oh, there's still Lickies.
There's some Licky Tongues and everything.
OK, onwards!
What's going on?
Oh my gosh.
Take
this!
Shoot!
No!
Oh my gosh.
They really took a number on me!
I was getting licked really bad.
Time to change.
Wow, that really got me bad.
Oh shoot.
Please, Devil Trigger!
Oh, I don't have Devil Trigger.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Guys, I'm gonna die.
He eats my Devil Trigger!
OK, I'm gonna Devil Trigger just so I can get some health back.
Holy cow.
One HP in a dream.
Oh, that doesn't sound very...
Oh my god, no!
It's the bat!
It's the freaking bat!
Oh my gosh, freaking bat.
It's me!
Oh my gosh, go.
Go Dante.
Just run.
Dante, just run.
Dante, just go.
They can't jump.
They're stupid.
Now this looks tight.
I don't know what's going on.
You guys, I'm just...
Do I have a Vital Star?
I do?
Oh my gosh, I can't go into the menu.
Oh, I can.
I do have one.
Holy moly.
OK.
Don't miss, Dante!
Why is that so far away?
Dante, don't miss.
Dante doesn't miss!
It's pulsating.
Can I get over there by jumping?
Nice.
Here we go!
This one wasn't so bad.
I got a C, but whatever.
OK.
Save, please.
I don't know how long it's going to take me to beat the rest of the game.
Honestly, I was like thinking I was going to be here for like 7 hours.
Did I say that?
As I might, it might take me 4 hours to beat the last 2 levels.
We'll see.
You're cruising?
I don't know about that.
Legendary battle?
Let's buy some Vital Stars.
A Vital Star.
I have a lot of Devil Stars.
I have one Holy Water.
Should I get an Untouchable?
It's either an Untouchable or a Holy Water.
Untouchable?
OK.
Untouchable is a good idea.
Holy Water won't help here.
Really?
Legendary battle.
Missions, start!
I'm getting married!
Wow, it's beautiful here.
Here comes the bride.
All dressed in red.
Table of contents.
Unlock every enemy file.
Trish!
Those are not around her wrists.
Oh no, I blinked too early!
How do I defeat a statue?
Here we are.
Those are not around her wrists.
My controller is really...
Trish!
Oh my god, she's dead.
Oh my god, she took the hit for me.
She saved me!
Oh god, he's got another one.
I went psycho mode.
I unlocked...
The Devil May Cry power.
How long are you going to keep yapping?
I mean zapping.
Real cutscene time.
Oh my god.
He's a zapper.
Oh my god!
Cover your bits please though.
No one wants to see that.
It got so quiet all of a sudden.
Are we...
This feels like...
This feels like a final battle.
She was hot.
Red eyes.
Mundus.
I turned into Sparda.
What the...
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
What is happening?
Oh my god, these controls are really evil.
Am
I?
These controls are so evil!
Just gotta keep holding down.
Wait, he's not taking any damage though.
Ouch!
Where?
What is hitting me?
Oh, I see his...
Oh
my god, this is so...
Oh my gosh.
I summoned a whole ass dragon!
Oh no.
I gotta take out the big balls again.
Guys, I'm almost there.
It's ok, I didn't need to use the vital on that.
It's ok.
How?
I probably gonna have to watch all the cutscenes again though.
Oh my gosh.
Let's just skip through the cutscenes.
Use D-pad for no inverse control?
Really?
Will that actually work?
And I can buy another vital star.
So I will.
And another untouchable.
Devil stars?
I have like 5 devil stars.
We're good.
I'm good on devil stars.
Oh wait, I have to go through this again.
If I just keep summoning dragons...
But he like...
Ok, hold on.
Oh, oh, ok, D-pad.
Oh wow, you guys are right.
Trying to get the...
Oh my gosh, he...
He summoned it so quickly.
Oh gosh.
It's really slow though, the D-pad.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
This fight is insane.
This fight is actually insane.
How the fuck is anybody supposed to do this?
What?
Oh my god.
Use the dodge?
What dodge?
Wait, A to move faster?
Oh, I can actually?
Press jump to fly faster.
Ok, hold on.
This is...
Yeah, this is a fight.
This is a fight.
And then they throw you right on in.
Ok guys, I gotta lock in.
I gotta lock in for real.
Can
I use it even when the balls are attached?
I mean, I don't know how else to say it.
Oh shoot.
Yes?
Oh, I can?
Oh, I can.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
Losing the game before I bought it?
Oh shit.
I love legendary battle on the track.
I forgot to buy it.
Oops.
This is gonna end badly with that rock.
Don't worry.
I saw it.
I'm preparing myself.
I'm mustering up the...
Ah, shoot.
Oh, that did end badly.
Ok, nevermind.
I attempted.
Oh my god.
I mean, you're just gonna get hit like that?
After all my hard work?
Getting hit by a living car?
Thanks for the gift, dude.
Phase 2.
Oh boy.
Oh my god.
I'm so slow all of a sudden.
What the hell do I do here?
I did it all of a sudden.
I knew my health was bad, but I just was trying to see what to do.
What do I...
How do I attack him?
Do I wait for the middle part to come up?
Ok.
Oops.
Alright.
Let's buy my stuff and then not forget to...
Ok.
So...
You know what?
What did I get before?
I got a vital star.
I got an untouchable.
And you know what?
I will get another devil star.
Why not?
Round trip.
What's that?
Oh, this one?
The one that I don't have enough orbs for because I just spent it all on things.
Slash and DT has extra range.
Ok.
You need to platform.
Yes, buy it.
Guys, I have no money.
I have no money.
It's all good.
Ok.
Ok, locking in.
Let's go.
Locking in.
I'm guessing...
Oh my gosh!
Ok, nevermind.
I did not see those.
Oh!
Dante!
Dante, you need to pay attention.
Why is it so loud all of a sudden?
I don't care.
I'm just gonna keep spamming it.
Yeah.
Wait!
Oh, I gotta use it.
I gotta use it.
One sec.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so almost dead.
I think I might die there.
I might die this round.
Probably.
I think I'll probably die.
Why not?
Another vital star.
Ok.
Sorry it got so loud all of a sudden in that one part.
It was kind of crazy.
Ok.
Ok, hold on.
Ok, my Devil Trigger is full.
We got the Sparda on.
Right?
Yeah, ok.
Wait, that means I can't...
Oh, I can Devil Trigger, but...
Interesting.
You can now.
So...
I saw someone say this and I'm gonna try it.
Untouchable!
Yes!
Devil Trigger!
And...
Wow,
that's kind of rude.
Oh my god.
He's just absorbing the damage.
Yes!
He's just eating it up.
How do I get him though?
Guys, I'm gonna die in the goop.
Guys, I'm in the goop.
Guys, I'm gonna die from the goop.
Oh, ok.
We're good, maybe?
I say good.
Good is like, you know, subjective.
Ouch.
Sword with DT?
I tried, but...
I...
I ran out.
At the very end.
Ok, hold on.
Oh, Devil Trigger?
Wait.
Oh, guys.
Guys, I'm gonna die in the...
I'm gonna die.
Goop is a good idea!
It doesn't really...
I got gooped, guys.
I got gooped.
I have no more heals.
Use shotgun against the orbs, really?
Oh.
If I can aim for...
Oh, wait.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, gosh.
Here they come.
Try the untouchable and Rambo melee in the lava.
Hmm.
You can use holy water during phase 2.
Really?
Ok, good to know.
We made...
He just eats so much of it, you know?
So maybe if I do sword when I untouchable instead of spam the thing...
Devastator, Vital...
Untouchable.
Stand on the closest platform and sword.
Ok.
Ok, ok, ok.
Ok!
We got this, guys!
We got this, guys.
And then round trip.
Yeah, the thing I don't have.
Locking in!
Can I hit him from this far away?
Do I have to be super close to him?
Oh, my God, why?
Sorry, I'm turning it way low.
Locking in!
Excuse me, can we not do double things, please?
I can only focus on one at a time.
Ok, I'm trying to get the dang orb, but...
They're just everywhere.
Ok.
You know what?
Ok, I got... No, I didn't get a single orb.
Ok.
There we go!
I'm DT!
And...
Yes!
DT!
Devastator!
There it is.
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
He's really far away.
Go, dragon!
Travel!
Ok.
Second form.
Let's go!
Oh, run away.
Alright, platforms inbound.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Don't do that.
Don't do that, please.
I don't like these.
Don't stop it.
Stop with your little spikes.
Oh, can I get up here?
Hey!
Ok.
No, I don't have a platform.
Oh my gosh!
I really don't have a platform now!
You asshole!
Oh, here we go.
Oh, nevermind.
Come on, DT!
DT!
Grab for the ledge!
Ok.
Ah, sorry.
I need a second to compose myself.
Ok.
Cheater!
Shut up.
If the game didn't want me to spam it, they wouldn't have let me.
Ok.
A DT and a slash attack.
DT.
Slash, slash, slash.
Slash slash slash.
Slash slash slash slash.
Slash slash slash slash slash.
Slash, slash, slash, slash, slash.
Slash, slash...
Okay, now I'm a baby.
And...
Tee-tee.
Tee-tee!
Slash, slash, slash, slash, slash.
Holy moly, this is doing numbers, baby.
Slash, don't hit me!
Oh, okay, you did nothing.
Oh, uh, you're hurting me a little bit, actually.
Slash, slash, slash, slash.
Please, Dante, don't...
Don't, don't fall in the water!
Dante, um...
Dante!
Slash, slash!
The final blow!
Yeah!
Slash, slash, slash, slash, slash!
I love to slash.
I'm the hash-slinging slasher.
Oh, Trish.
My fake mom.
Do you have my mom's memories now?
Oh, her hair is so...
Spaghetti.
Making me hungry.
My mother risked her life for me.
And now you, too.
Say the line, here it comes.
I should have saved you.
I should have been the one to fill your dark soul with light!
Why?
Oh no, Dante!
This was my mother's.
Now I'm giving it to you.
I should have been the one to fill your dark soul with light!
Rest... in peace.
Oh my gosh, that'd be...
Why?
I have six rorbs.
Hey, I got a C.
C's get degrees, baby.
I should have been the one...
Sorry, I can't stop quoting it.
It's so funny.
I collected 25,000 rorbs!
Oh my gosh, we're on the final mission, guys!
Chapter 23.
Good work.
Thanks, Ham!
Oh my gosh, I actually had tears running down my face from laughing at that.
That's so funny.
Wait...
Mother's guide.
Escape Mallet Island before it collapses!
Guys, do I need to buy anything here, or...?
It's time.
No, just run.
You're good.
Okay.
I need to run.
Mission start!
I have five minutes.
Okay.
Uh, how do I get out?
Uh...
Oh gosh, uh...
Wait, does someone mention that door to...
Oh, a door to darkness?
Oh yes, me.
Okay, this way?
Uh...
Oh shoot, uh...
Ignore him.
Uh, wait, it's over here.
This one.
Okay.
Ah!
DT runs faster.
We're true!
Sorry, it's so...
Wait, come on!
Please!
Dante!
Slice!
Just slice the thing, Dante!
Dante!
Just slice it!
Wait, can I not?
Do I have to...
Oh my god.
Do I have to beat these guys?
Oh.
Oh, no, please.
Yeah!
Please, please, Dante.
You're just taking...
You're just eating attacks.
Nice, I got a big ol' orb.
Please!
Oh my god.
I'm not gonna make it, am I?
Okay.
All right.
Open up, please.
He's dead!
I don't care about the raw arms!
Oh, um, get in there.
Get in there, Dante.
Dante.
Do I just stand?
Uh, hello?
Um.
Uh, guys?
Examine?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, thank you.
I didn't know the action, but I thought it would be automatic.
Oh, wrong way, wrong way, wrong way.
Oh, gosh.
There we go.
Slow and steady.
Escape Mallet Island before it collapses!
Mission startle!
Uh...
Oh, gosh!
Wait, what the hell?
Um...
Oh my god, just go!
Just leave, Dante!
I think I'm going the right way.
Oh, shit.
You've got to defeat the enemy!
You bitch!
Just die!
Die!
I gotta get out of here, okay?
Gosh!
Grab that.
Can I leave?
Can I leave now?
Okay.
Nice.
Now we should be at the entrance.
Oh, nope.
Just kidding.
I don't know where I...
Oh, no!
No...
I'm down here?
Oh my gosh, they're making us go to every...
No, why?
Uh-oh.
Boss?
Boss fight?
Wait, how am I supposed to get out?
No way.
Okay.
Phase three.
This guy...
Sucks so much.
I'm gonna do this again?
Yeah, look around.
Oh, yeah, baby!
Oh my god.
Woo!
Double trigger, baby.
Wait.
I'm not doing any damage all of a sudden.
Why am I not doing any damage all of a sudden?
I
think I'm doing it.
This texture is so awesome.
Hello?
Aren't you supposed to be dead?
No, it's okay, Dante.
You got this.
You'll be okay.
Mom!
You can do it.
What?
Mother.
Oh my god.
It's Trish!
Feed your power and Trish's power into your guns, Ebony and Ivory.
Then use your double trigger and blast a big shot at the Mundus.
Wait, how do I...
Wait.
Okay.
I can't believe we're going back to...
Oh, it is all...
They're already selected.
Okay.
Ebony and Ivory, baby!
Yeah, baby!
You're sticking licky tongues.
I don't want...
I don't even know if I'm doing anything, to be honest.
Yeah!
Double trigger!
It looks like we have a winner.
Jackpot.
I sure hope not.
See you later, Mundus.
Goodbye.
And when you do come back, give my regards to my son, will ya?
What?
What do you mean by that?
What did you mean by that?
Trish.
Oh my gosh.
That's your mom-ish.
Trish mom-ish.
What did he mean by that?
Oh no!
Oh
no!
What does that mean?
I think...
I think she means about the building collapsing.
If only he were like Raiden and he could slice it.
A plane?
Wait, do I have to pilot this thing?
No way.
Oh my god.
Oh, it fights!
Oh, it shoots!
Oh my god.
Let's rock!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, no, no.
I feel like I'm in a goddamn Islands of Adventure ride.
Oops, oops, my bad.
I thought it would blast it.
My bad for not realizing that it would work.
Can I lower myself, please?
Okay, so the D-pad is also...
Oh, it is inverted.
It's not inverted.
Okay, great.
Um, I'm just...
We're fine.
Yeah, we made it!
Yeah!
Oh, we did it!
Oh, her hair is really long.
Oh, it's gone now.
Your voice is so quiet.
What'd you say, Trish?
Yeah, so deep.
We play DMC2, pick Lucia instead.
Campaign is shorter and less painful.
Oh, it's it.
Thank you.
Thanks, Leon.
Thanks for the super chat.
Wow, we did it!
Yeah.
Tails!
Yippee, we did it!
Devil never cry.
Wait.
Wasn't it Devil May Cry before?
They changed the name, even?
Woo!
Five minutes.
Yay!
Team Little Devils!
Oh my gosh, we did it!
We did it!
Oh my gosh, we did it so much more quickly than I thought.
This was supposed to be an endurance stream.
Why does she have my sword?
I didn't give you permission to use that, Trish.
Oh, they're like sword dancing.
This is so romantic.
Are they supposed to be romantic?
So cool.
Thanks for always filling our dark souls with love.
Thanks, Dark Raider.
Not really.
It's his mom.
Okay, but like...
It's not really his mom.
Thanks, Althezero!
Thanks for the playthrough.
I'm gonna be thinking about that all day.
Packing up with a woman that looks exactly like his mom.
Truly living the dream.
I don't...
I mean...
He could be a mama's boy.
We don't know.
But also, what happened with his brother?
What happened with Virgil?
What happened with him?
So begins the legend of Dante and his demon mom, GF.
Not blood related.
Time for DMC3.
Future games?
Okay.
No spoilers, guys.
I'm just asking.
But I'm like...
You know, not wanting an actual answer.
You have to be like...
You'll have to play to find out!
That kind of deal.
Oedipus is truly too strong.
Congrats, your reward for clearing DMC1 is to finally understand the response to DMC2.
After that, it's all uphill from there.
Oh, the music is so awesome.
David Keighley.
Seeds of Love.
Asawa Spring.
Uh-oh, new karaoke song.
From what I understand, this series is also like...
Out of timeline order, right?
Dragon!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Virgil's just chilling.
Light emoji.
Dante is one of those video game protagonists who does not know what sex is.
Okay, I think I get it.
Three is the first in the story.
I see, I see, I see.
First one chronologically.
If you do not play DMC2, please don't make it not make you play three.
Three is amazing.
No, no, I don't think there would ever be...
You guys, you guys know how patient I am typically with games.
There's never usually a game that will stop me from playing a series.
Even if I'll...
No matter how frustrated I get in a game.
Yay!
Finished the game on normal mode!
Warming up is what it's called.
What do I get?
Seeds get degrees, baby.
The final C.
Don't worry about it in the series.
Everyone gets laid, but Dante.
C for cool.
The music box is so nice.
Everybody is so angry about two.
It makes me just even that much more curious.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, wow.
Oh, I only got two stylish combos.
I think those were last stream.
Two tough games beaten in two days.
Nobody can gout...
Oh, can gout.
And doubt.
Minto is a gamer.
Also, everybody, please check out her upcoming 3.0 debut.
Thank you, Marilyn!
Thanks for the pick!
Oh, gout.
I combined gamer and doubt.
Guys, you know how my brain works, okay?
You know that I'm always combining words, okay?
We got 27,000 rorbs.
Only nine retries.
What?
That doesn't seem correct.
That doesn't seem right.
I died way more times than that.
I never got an A, but I got a few Bs.
It's not bad.
My average is probably okay.
People are critical of two because you start the game playing as Dante, but then they pull the rug on you and you play as Raiden.
You had me in the first half, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, the yorbs.
So many dulls.
Sorry.
My combos are lame.
If you play two, I'll live it through for the first time through you.
I gave it an hour and was like, yeah, three is really good though.
Is it just bad gameplay or is it...
Bad story?
Bad everything?
Too stylish is better than some people.
Thank you.
It's not fun.
It's really boring.
Oh, really?
Wait, I don't want to stream a boring game.
Dull presentation.
Dante barely talks?
Oh no, it's MGSV.
It's unfinished?
Oh no, it's really MGSV.
It had dev hell.
Oh, I see.
I'll consider it.
I still haven't figured out when I can play the next game yet, so...
In the meantime, I'll just consider it.
If you didn't want you to...
If they didn't want you to stinger combo everything to death, they wouldn't have let you do it five games in a row.
Drop it if you fall asleep.
I don't want to play a boring game.
It's only five hours though.
Oh, I can beat it in one stream then maybe?
You should see it for yourself though.
I feel like if I want to be a true Devil May Cry fan, I need to do everything, you know?
I also feel that way about Metal Gear.
I have to play the good, the bad and the ugly.
I want to not be just a fan of something and then...
You know, do...
Not be like, oh, what did you think of 2?
And I say, oh, I don't know.
I watch the YouTube videos about it.
You know what I mean?
I have to be a real fan of something.
I have to appreciate and learn every good thing and bad thing about it.
Play it, but if you get bored, just drop it.
What if I could beat it in five hours?
I could just take a day to do it, huh?
Go challenge the hard mode.
Okay, shut up, Dante.
I'm tired.
Save.
Yeah, let's save.
Eight hours.
Well, I guess that's not so bad for me running around and my first time trying the game.
Oh, no.
Yeah, we did it.
Treated as a footnote in the lore.
It's not important in the other games.
You are the strongest MGS fan I've ever seen.
I think I'm just...
I'm more tolerant than...
Like, in certain ways.
Like, some people will be like, oh, this game was so horrible.
And I'll be like, oh, it's whatever.
You know.
Set the difficulty to easy and speedrun it.
See if you can get a world record.
Should we try?
Wait, I don't know if you can speedrun something, though.
Your first time.
Give it a shot.
Unless it is absolutely extremely...
Oh my gosh.
Nicholas, how did your super chat get through when you had a bad word?
You got this.
Thank you.
Devil may cry.
Can we replay some bad ace combat?
It really takes a lot...
Like, if only it's like...
Real...
I like how I'm just watching this.
Slow down, babe.
I'm just watching this cutscene again.
So great.
Uh, it really takes...
I don't know.
Some people have asked me, like, what's a really bad game...
Am I correct?
And there definitely are some.
I can't think of anything right now.
Atla Enesto Nazo.
But even that, I didn't have...
It didn't take me as long as I expected.
You could say my favorite game.
I can take it.
In that case, you should be used to this sort of thing.
Madison?
Okay, game.
I'm trying to talk.
Madison?
I played Madison.
I found it...
I found it spooky up until the very last part of the game.
I had to force myself to beat the MC two...
Two times.
Why did you do that?
That's so bad.
I love Ebony and Ivory.
Let's go, girls!
Got the platinum trophy.
You guys are so strong.
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done.
Yay!
We did it, guys!
Holy cow.
Wait, is it just starting the game over for me?
Wait, is it actually just...
Oh my god!
Why am I here?
I have double jump!
Wait...
Do I keep all my stuff?
There's a Yorb in there and I never knew!
Oh wait, maybe I did know.
Oh yeah, I knew.
Oh my gosh, new game plus is awesome.
Hahaha, new game plus is amazing!
Yorb in the tower.
What tower?
In there?
Oh my god, can you guys...
We're far away so you can barely...
Listen...
You can barely...
You can barely hear his jumps.
Oh, here.
I think this is a fine place to leave it.
Us looking off into the distance while the birds fly and we look at the sunset.
It's the last day of summer.
Oh my friends, I haven't been acting it myself.
I've been having these weird dreams.
Roxas, I'm eating my sea salt ice cream.
Feels like MGS.
Yeah, this is also very...
Um, how...
How do I do the music for the...
That area?
Wait, I hear it in my head but I can't produce it with my mouth.
I guess my summer vacation is over.
Twilight's Night Pink?
Yeah, that's the one I'm thinking of but I can't make it with my mouth.
I think the strongest fans can appreciate that the bad games exist and can love the better games more.
For instance, I loved Resident Evil Orc and Dark Souls 3.
But I can acknowledge they're not as good.
Yeah, I respect that.
I also think like, you know, for the most part...
Even like, I try to remember that for games...
One, I can't make a game.
And I know that for a lot of games they have many factors that go into why they can become bad.
You know, whether it's like time crunch or...
Or just all sorts of issues that can arise.
But you know one thing that's not forgiving?
Is that damn Uzumaki anime.
They had five years.
I'm so... Poor Jujito.
All of his works just end up so cursed.
Oh gosh, every episode there's just something that comes out about it.
And I'm like, god damn it.
How does it get worse and worse?
It's now to the point where it's like...
South Park animation.
Oh, I meant Dead Space 3.
Some people were like, wait, Dead Souls 3 is great.
What are you on about?
Dead Space.
Jujito is the epitome of the manga is better.
But the first episode was great!
Apparently.
Reminder that Dante and Raiden appeared in one game together.
What game?
This is my money hole.
It was made for me, studios.
Wrong Dante.
Uh-oh, you're making people mad.
PlayStation All-Stars?
Oh, I do know that game.
I do know that game.
I was thinking of playing it because I have Metal Gear in it.
Thanks for the donation.
Streaming on my birthday!
Honored to share a birthday month with you.
I can't wait for your re-debut.
Rusty, thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Rusty the Squire.
Happy birthday!
Well, guys, I think I'll end it there then.
We can end on a birthday song.
Thank you guys for...
I really thought I started this so early in the night.
Because I was like, I'm going to be going all night, baby.
Or so early in the day.
So, sorry.
Oh, kind of cursed.
Sorry if it was like at a non-opportune time for you to watch.
But I hope you enjoyed the finale of Devil May Cry.
And, well, we'll play Devil May Cry 2.
I guess eventually sometime.
If you are like, no, don't play it.
You just don't have to watch.
That's all good.
Or you can wait for Devil May Cry 3.
No worries.
All good, all good.
Is this Blade Runner?
Gosh, I want to play Blade Runner so bad.
Can we play Blade Runner?
I've been wanting to play that for a long time.
That's a game?
Yes, it's...
Oh my gosh.
I used to play it with my dad when I was a kid.
Blade Runner has a game.
Yes, I used to play it when I was a kid.
With my dad.
Well, my dad would play and I would get scared.
Okay, I'm gonna play it in a couple weeks.
Okay, okie dokie.
Okie dokie, everybody.
Thank you very much.
Have a great night.
Or great day.
Or whatever time it is for you.
Get some rest.
Regardless, drink some water.
Stretch and hydrate.
All that good stuff.
And the devil doesn't cry.
Yeah!
I think I know that game.
It was made by Westwood.
What game?
Oh, the Blade Runner one?
I have no...
I think that sounds familiar.
Okay.
I should've been the one to fill your dark soul with light.
Otsumita!
Bye, bye, bye, bye.
See you.
Bye, bye.